what is the meaning of this thing we got
going on what is the meaning of life
you're you're saving the softball for
the end
easy one i i don't know what the meaning
of life is i i think there's something
that characterizes us
that's not the thing that people
normally think characterizes us
the traditional thing to say in the
philosophical tradition even in the ai
tradition which is a kind of um
manifestation
of philosophy from plato forward the
traditional thing to say is that what
characterizes us is our
rationality that we're intelligent
beings that we're the ones that that
think
and i think that's certainly part of of
what characterizes us
but i think there's
more to it too i think we're capable
of
experiencing
simultaneously
the complete and utter ungroundedness of
everything that's meaningful in our
existence
and also the real significance of it and
that sounds like
that sounds like a contradiction like
how could it really be significant and
not be based on anything
but i think that's the contradiction
that somehow characterizes us and i
think that
are the being that sort of has to hold
that weird mystery before us and live
in the light of it that's the thing that
i think is really at our core and so how
do we do that i i will say this one
thing
um and i learned it from a philosopher
from a guy named albert borgmon who's a
joe german philosopher lived in montana
now taught in montana for his whole
career
and when i i say this to my students at
harvard now he said this is the way that
i think about my life and i hope you'll
think about your life too
he said you should think about your life
hoping
that there will be many moments in it
about which you can say
there's no place i'd rather be
there's
no thing i'd rather be doing
there's no
buddy i'd rather be with
and this i will remember well
and i think if you can aim to fill your
life with moments like that it will be a
meaningful one i don't know if that's
the meaning of life
but i think if you can hold that before
you it'll help to clarify this mystery
and this sort of bizarre situation in
which we find ourselves
sean this conversation was incredible
and those four requirements have
certainly been fulfilled for me
this was a magical moment
in that way and i will remember it well
thank you so much it's an honor that you
spend your valuable time with me this is
great thank you thank you for having me
lex i really really enjoyed it
you